the house committee investigating the
assault on the capitol is getting new
evidence that could help it fill in some
gaps in its knowledge it's coming
because the biden administration has
cleared the release of trump white house
visitor logs including logs from that
fateful day january 6 2021.
scott mcfarlane is on capitol hill for
us scott good morning this could fill in
some gaps indeed hey tony good morning
the national archives says it will
provide those records to the house
january 6 committee in two weeks after
president biden again rejects his
predecessor's claim of executive
privilege those visitor logs are
expected to show who was on the grounds
in those pivotal hours before the riot
began we know the january 6 committee
has been probing who the former
president spoke with by phone that day
what he said to mike pence by phone from
the oval office and who was nearby when
he said it meanwhile the federal judge
says he'll decide by tomorrow whether to
hold stewart rhodes the accused oath
keepers founder in pre-trial detention
in his seditious conspiracy case rhodes
has pleaded not guilty and on a hearing
wednesday his lawyers argued he's not a
danger and is in fact very eager for a
very public trial in his case his
lawyers tell me they're going to argue
the oath keepers were in town that day
on a protective mission for vips at the
trump rally prosecutors say he's a risk
of flight a risk of witness tampering
rhodes says he's not but we'll see what
happens when rhodes is back in court
here tomorrow afternoon
nate
scott thank you